This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Way back in the 3rd century AD, among in the Egyptian desert, warned of evil spirits people should try to overcome. In Christianity, these became known as the Seven Deadly Sents. Pride, gluttony, greed, lust, sloth, wrath and one more. Envy. It's an ugly, miserable, unflattering emotion and it's universal.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆 (Shankar Vedantam)。早在公元3世纪，埃及沙漠中的隐士就曾警告世人要努力克服心中的恶魔。在基督教中，这些被称为七宗罪：傲慢、暴食、贪婪、色欲、怠惰、愤怒，还有一个。嫉妒。这是一种丑陋、痛苦、不讨喜的情绪，而且它无处不在。
Everyone at some time or another will experience this feeling of wanting what someone else has and resenting them for having it. Hi, my name is Jessica Kyle from Atlanta, Georgia. In 2014, Jessica and her best friend traveled to the remote Komoros islands in the Indian Ocean. They were there to teach English. It was meant to be a grand adventure and could have been a high point in their friendship. Except Jessica and her friend got sick, really sick, with Denge fever.
每个人在人生的某个时刻，都会体验到这种渴望得到别人拥有之物，并因别人拥有而心生怨恨的感觉。嗨，我叫杰西卡·凯尔 (Jessica Kyle)，来自佐治亚州亚特兰大。2014年，杰西卡和她最好的朋友前往印度洋偏远的科摩罗群岛。她们去那里教英语。这本该是一场伟大的冒险，也本可以成为她们友谊的高光时刻。然而，杰西卡和她的朋友生病了，病得很重，感染了登革热。
I was single and she was married to a doctor and her husband was really worried about her and was able to get her evacuated to Kenya. To Nairobi, to be exact, to a hospital with air conditioning, good food, and excellent medical care. Jessica, meanwhile, was stuck on the island, where it was about 100 degrees and we had no electricity and I was very hot and didn't have any good food. Jessica couldn't stop thinking about how her friend was getting much better care than she was. Now, besides being sick, Jessica felt she was suffering from a new malaise. I was really, really envious of her to the point where it was actually physically painful, other than just having Dange fever, that envy I felt because I wanted to be in her place.
当时我是单身，而她嫁给了一名医生，她丈夫非常担心她的病情，设法将她撤离到了肯尼亚。准确地说，是内罗毕的一家医院，那里有空调、好吃的食物和极佳的医疗护理。与此同时，杰西卡却被困在这个岛上，那里气温高达100华氏度（约38摄氏度），没有电，天气非常热，也没有任何好吃的。杰西卡情不自禁地想着，为什么她的朋友能得到比她好得多的照顾。现在，除了生病，杰西卡觉得她还饱受一种新的精神困扰。我真的非常非常嫉妒她，甚至达到了身体上都感到痛苦的程度。除了得登革热本身的痛苦之外，我感受到的那种嫉妒是因为我渴望取代她的位置。
Indeed, that is the purpose of envy. It's a tool for social comparison. It cues you into your relative position among friends, colleagues, and peers. In Jessica's case, she was clearly in a weaker position than her friend. The envy was sounding the alarm. Jessica did eventually recover, as did her friend, and when they were reunited, Jessica told her friend about the pain of being abandoned. And it took several conversations with her when she got back on the island, explaining how much I was hurt by that, knowing it wasn't her fault. But still needing to get those feelings out there. She's still one of my best friends and I did get over it eventually, but it was really, really hard. Of course, not all stories of envy end with growth and understanding. Very often, envy leads to wicked places and tragic consequences. People started sending me a link to a story about people in the Gaza Strip
确实，这就是嫉妒的目的。它是一种进行社会比较的工具。它能让你了解自己在朋友、同事和同龄人中的相对位置。就杰西卡而言，她显然处于比朋友更弱势的地位。嫉妒敲响了警钟。杰西卡最终康复了，她的朋友也是如此。当她们重聚时，杰西卡向朋友倾诉了被抛弃的痛苦。当她回到岛上时，我们经过了好几次谈话，我向她解释了这种抛弃对我的伤害有多大，尽管我知道这不是她的错。但我仍然需要把那些感受宣泄出来。她依然是我最好的朋友之一，我最终也放下了这件事，但这真的非常非常难。当然，并非所有关于嫉妒的故事都以成长和理解告终。很多时候，嫉妒会把人引向邪恶的境地和悲剧的后果。人们开始给我发一个链接，讲述加沙地带的人们的故事，
or people in Israel who were sitting on their couches watching bombs get lobbed at the other side and cheering. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring you a favorite episode from 2018 that delves deeply into an emotion most of us prefer to hide. It's an emotion that can have a positive side prompting us to take steps to improve our lives. prompting us to take steps to improve our lives, but envy can often turn malicious, prompting us to resentment, rage, even revenge. It's hard to imagine life
或者以色列人坐在沙发上看着炮弹被投向敌方并欢呼雀跃。本周的 Hidden Brain，我们为您带来2018年的一期热门节目，深入探讨大多数人更愿意隐藏的一种情绪。这是一种既有积极一面、能促使我们采取行动改善生活的情绪，促使我们采取行动改善生活，但嫉妒往往会变成恶意的，促使我们产生怨恨、愤怒甚至报复。很难想象没有快乐的愉悦或深切悲伤的痛苦的生活，
without the pleasure of happiness or the pain of deep sadness. These emotions help make us whole. They give us a way to understand life in all its beauty and suffering. But an emotion like envy is entirely different. It feels repugnant, useless. But of course, that's far from the truth. Envy in fact, drives us in fascinating ways, sometimes making us better
没有这些，生活将不完整。这些情绪帮助我们成为完整的人。它们为我们提供了一种理解生活中所有美丽与苦难的方式。但像嫉妒这样情绪则完全不同。它让人感到厌恶、毫无用处。但当然，这远非事实。事实上，嫉妒以迷人的方式驱动着我们，有时让我们变得更好，
people, sometimes not. To understand it, we begin where any good conversation on N.V. should begin, with Homer Simpson. Homer is an excellent example of pretty much all the seven deadly scents. He's lazy. I'm just a big toasty cinnamon bun. I never want to leave this bed. And gluttonous. Mmm, 64 slices of American cheese. 64.
有时则不然。为了理解它，我们从任何关于嫉妒的精彩对话都该开始的地方讲起——也就是荷马·辛普森 (Homer Simpson)。荷马可以说是集七宗罪于一身的绝佳例子。他很懒。我只是一块烤得焦黄的肉桂卷。我永远都不想离开这张床。而且还很贪吃。嗯，64片美国芝士。64片。
63. And greedy. Where's my money? Where's my money? Homer is also consumed with envy, especially if his do-gooder neighbor, Net Flanders. You know, if you gave Net Flanders a chance. Oh, here we go again. Look, I don't care if Netflander is the nicest guy in the world. He's a jerk. Homer can't stand flanders. Why? Well, flander is a pillar of the community.
63。并且贪婪。我的钱呢？我的钱呢？荷马也被嫉妒吞噬着，尤其是当他面对那个老好人邻居内德·弗兰德斯 (Ned Flanders) 时。你知道的，如果你给内德·弗兰德斯一个机会。哦，又来了。听着，我才不管内德·弗兰德斯是不是世界上最好的人呢。他就是个混蛋。荷马对弗兰德斯恨之入骨。为什么？嗯，弗兰德斯是社区的中流砥柱。
He's got a nicer house, a fancier grill, a better job. End of story. Well, we can't hold it against them, just because he has things a little better than we do. Excuse me? Better? Thanks a lot, Marge. You really put me in my plate.
他有一栋更好的房子，一个更高级的烤架，一份更好的工作。就这样。好吧，我们不能因为他过得比我们稍微好一点就怪他。什么？过得更好？多谢了，玛吉。你真把我架在火上烤啊。
Oh, ho, ho, ho. Don't get me wrong. It's worth feeling three inches tall to find out what kind of a person you really are. Marge Simpson, president of the International. We love Flanders fan club. Usually, Homer has left us two in his own bitter bile, but one day Flanders does something unusual. He announces he's quitting his job.
哦，吼，吼，吼。别误会我的意思。为了弄清楚你究竟是个什么样的人，哪怕感觉自己矮了三寸也是值得的。玛吉·辛普森，国际“我们爱弗兰德斯”粉丝俱乐部会长。通常情况下，荷马只会把我们俩留在自己的痛苦和嫉妒中，但有一天，弗兰德斯做了一件不同寻常的事。他宣布要辞职。
As a Friday, I'm saying too low to the pharmaceutical game. Leaving, I can't believe it. What was he talking about? No, I kid you not. What are you going to do, Ned? Well, sir, like one out of every nine Americans, I'm left-handed. And let me tell you, they know all peaches and gream.
从周五开始，我要对制药行业说再见了。辞职，我简直不敢相信。他在说什么？不，我没开玩笑。你打算怎么办，内德？嗯，先生，就像九分之一的美国人一样，我是左撇子。而且我告诉你们，他们的日子可不像想象的那么好过。
You're writing it smeared. Lord, help you if you want to drive a standard transmission. Amen. Well, sir, I'm opening up a one-stop store for southpaws. Everything from left-handed apple, pillars to left-handed zithers. Gotta call it the left-torium. Ooh! The left-torium.
你的书写都会被蹭脏。上帝保佑你想开手动挡的车。阿门。好吧，先生，我要开一家专门为左撇子服务的全方位商店。从左撇子苹果削皮器到左撇子齐特琴，应有尽有。我打算叫它“左撇子天地”。哦！左撇子天地。
A store with gadgets for left-handed people. Finally, Homer feels he has the upper hand. The left-torium, he Homer feels he has the upper hand. The leftorium, he believes, is a truly stupid idea. Homer dreams that it will finally lead to Flanders' downfall. I'm telling you, Flanders' store was deserted. So what do you think of your bestest buddy, No, Mark? Dad, do you know what Shodden in Florida is? No I do not know what
一家专为左撇子提供小玩意的商店。终于，荷马觉得他占了上风。“左撇子天地”，他——荷马觉得他占了上风。“左撇子天地”，他坚信，这是一个极其愚蠢的主意。荷马梦想着这最终会导致弗兰德斯的垮台。我跟你说，弗兰德斯的店里冷冷清清。所以你对你最好的哥们有什么看法，诺曼？爸爸，你知道什么是幸灾乐祸吗？不，我不知道什么是
shot in Florida is. Please tell me because I'm dying to know. It's a German town for shameful joy, taking pleasure in the suffering of others. Oh come on Lisa, I'm just glad to see him fall flat on his butt. He's usually all happy and comfortable and surrounded by loved ones and it makes me feel! What's the opposite of that shameful joy thing here? Sour grapes. Boy, those Germans have a word for everything! Hard-of-walk makes Homer Simpson such an interesting character,
幸灾乐祸。请告诉我，因为我急于想知道。这是一个德语词，意思是可耻的快乐，从别人的痛苦中获取快乐。噢，拜托，丽莎，我只是很高兴看到他摔个狗吃屎。他平时总是那么快乐、安逸，被爱人环绕，这让我感觉——那个可耻的快乐东西的反义词是什么？酸葡萄。天哪，德国人对什么都有一个词！是什么让荷马·辛普森成为这样一个有趣的角色，
is that he happily and openly expresses thoughts and feelings, many of us secretly identify with, including En envy and its nasty sidekick, Shadden Freude. Envy taps into a dark side of human behavior, but that doesn't mean it's without value. Like all emotions, it has a purpose. The anthropologist Christopher Bohm has written extensively on the hierarchies that have long existed among our ancestors, both early hunter-gatherer tribes and our primate relatives.
在于他快乐且公开地表达了许多我们暗中认同的想法和感受，包括嫉妒及其讨厌的帮凶——幸灾乐祸。嫉妒触及了人类行为黑暗的一面，但这并不意味着它毫无价值。像所有情绪一样，它有其目的。人类学家克里斯托弗·博姆 (Christopher Boehm) 对我们的祖先（包括早期的狩猎采集部落和我们的灵长类亲属）长期存在的等级制度进行了广泛的研究。
Christopher makes two points about the origins of envy. The first, inequality, is everywhere. In a hunter-gathered group, there are always individuals who are more gifted, individuals who are more intelligent, individuals who are more attractive socially or sexually and so on. So there are considerable number of inequalities within even a egalitarian society. The other point Christopher makes is that such differences matter. They're not lost on the members of a tribe. Even primates pay attention to social ranking, who has less, who has more.
克里斯托弗对嫉妒的起源提出了两点看法。首先，不平等无处不在。在一个狩猎采集群体中，总有一些人更有天赋，一些人更聪明，一些人社交或性吸引力更强，等等。因此，即使在一个平均主义社会中，也存在相当数量的不平等。克里斯托弗指出的另一点是，这些差异至关重要。部落成员对这些差异心知肚明。甚至灵长类动物也会关注社会等级：谁拥有的少，谁拥有的多。
Over half a century ago, a primatologist named Chance wrote an article on Baboon behavior in which he discussed the direction of attention in the group. And he simply measured where different individuals' gazes were directed in a systematic way. He found that the alpha male, no surprise, was gazed at ever so much more than anybody else. And it wasn't just the alpha male. Every member seemed to be intimately aware of where he or she stood in the hierarchy of the tribe. This combination, the reality of inequalities, and the fact that we are hardwired to notice them, this is the fuel for our endless capacity for envy. Mena Chicara, a social psychologist at Harvard, says it's exactly the same with humans. We make sense of the world through social comparisons. When you meet a new person, there are a lot of things about them that you register immediately,
半个多世纪前，一位名叫钱斯 (Chance) 的灵长类动物学家发表了一篇关于狒狒行为的文章，他在文章中探讨了群体中注意力的方向。他以系统的方式简单地测量了不同个体的视线投向何处不足为奇的是，他发现阿尔法雄星受到了比其他任何人都多得多的注视。而且不仅仅是阿尔法雄星。每个成员似乎都对自己在部落等级制度中的地位了如指掌。这种不平等的现实、以及我们生来就会注意到它们的生理机能，这两者的结合，正是我们产生无尽嫉妒之心的燃料。哈佛大学的社会心理学家梅娜·奇卡拉 (Mena Chicara) 表示，人类的情况完全一样。我们通过社会比较来理解世界。当你遇到一个新的人时，关于他们有很多事情你会立刻注意到，
but you don't just register them in some abstract or absolute sense, you register them relative to yourself. So not just how tall is this person, but how much taller or shorter are they than I am? We do this because the comparison tells us where we fit in. What are places in the human hierarchy? What's more, it alerts us to imbalances that might need our attention. Sometimes the comparisons we make don't matter that much.
但你不仅是在某种抽象或绝对的意义上去注意到它们，你是相对于你自己来注意到它们的。所以不仅是这个人有多高，而是他们比我高多少或矮多少？我们这样做是因为这种比较告诉了我们自己的定位。我们在人类等级制度中的位置是什么？更重要的是，它提醒我们注意可能需要我们关注的不平衡。有时我们进行的比较并没有那么重要。
I might look at my colleague, Steve Innski, and notice he not only hosts a popular public radio program. It's morning edition from NPR News. But he also manages to find time to write a new book nearly every other year. I feel envious of Steve but in a way sociologist call Benign. I don't wish anything bad to happen to him. I just wish that I was more like him. Okay, Shaker, thanks very much. Maybe the feeling might push me to work harder. So if you have more than what I have, I may be inspired by what you have.
我可能会看着我的同事史蒂夫·因斯基 (Steve Inskeep)，注意到他不仅主持着一个广受欢迎的公共广播节目——那是来自NPR新闻的《早间版》(Morning Edition)——而且他几乎每隔一年就能抽出时间写一本新书。我感到嫉妒史蒂夫，但这种嫉妒是社会学家所称的良性嫉妒。我并不希望他发生什么不好的事情。我只是希望自己能更像他一点。好的，香卡，非常感谢。这种感觉可能会促使我更加努力工作。所以如果你拥有的比我多，我可能会被你所拥有的东西所激励。
And so I may have, I may experience these benign forms of envy, which could also manifest as admiration. I remember this one time in college, I was going with two girlfriends to go shopping and they were about to buy a new table for their apartment they were getting together. This is Leah Morthy from Houston, Texas. On that shopping trip with friends, she found herself suffering from benign envy.
因此，我可能会体验到这些良性的嫉妒形式，这也可能表现为钦佩。我记得在大学里有一次，我和两个女朋友去逛街，她们正准备为合租的公寓买一张新桌子。这是来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的莉亚·莫蒂 (Leah Morthy)。在和朋友一起购物的那次经历中，她发现自己患上了良性嫉妒。
One of the friends had just gotten married to a senior who had graduated and he was out somewhere else in the country making money and she had she checked her bank account before we left and she had a $1,500 in there and that was a substantial amount of money to me back in college days where you know I only had a few hundred dollars on a good day in my bank account. Leah was envious of her friend and the kind of table she could afford. She made it a goal one day to get her own nice table. My first table that I bought for my apartment was $15 from Goodwill.
其中一个朋友刚嫁给一个已经毕业的大四学生，他在国内的某个地方赚钱。她离开前查了查自己的银行账户，里面有1500美元，对于我当年在大学里的时候来说，这是一大笔钱了，你知道的，我手头宽裕的时候银行账户里也就几百美元。莉亚嫉妒她的朋友以及她买得起的那种桌子。她把有一天拥有自己漂亮的桌子定为一个目标。我为我的公寓买的第一张桌子是花15美元从古德威尔 (Goodwill) 买的。
Of course it didn't last, but years later when we saved and we were patient my husband and I, and we finally were able to buy a good table, it's been with us for almost 10 years now. And I think of learning that patience when it came to money and time was a very good lesson. So Leah's envy motivated her to plan and save and build the kind of life she wanted. And it worked. But envy doesn't always work in this happy fashion.
当然它没用多久，但多年以后，当我们存了钱，我和我丈夫都保持了耐心，我们终于买得起一张好桌子时，它已经陪伴了我们快10年了。我认为，学会对金钱和时间保持耐心是非常好的一课。因此，莉亚的嫉妒激励她去规划、去储蓄，并建立她想要的生活。而且这奏效了。但嫉妒并不总是以这种快乐的方式发挥作用。
In fact, there's evidence that envy makes us unhappy and there are ever more sources of envy in our modern world. In an earlier episode of Hidden Brain, we featured the researcher O'Hard Barzile, who conducted a study into the effects that Facebook has on our lives. He compared the mental well-being of people using the site regularly against a control group that was prevented from using Facebook. Our first finding is that using Facebook make you more comparative. You compare yourself to others more often.
事实上，有证据表明嫉妒会让我们不快乐，而在我们现代世界中，嫉妒的来源越来越多。在早期的 Hidden Brain 节目中，我们邀请了研究人员奥哈德·巴兹莱 (Ohad Barzile)，他进行了一项关于脸书 (Facebook) 对我们生活影响的研究。他将经常使用该网站的人的心理健康状况与一个被禁止使用脸书的对照组进行了比较。我们的第一个发现是，使用脸书会让你更倾向于比较。你更经常地将自己与他人进行比较。
You judge yourself, you compare am I better or worse than my friends and my happier, are they happier and so on. Oh, I had found that spending time on social media puts people in a mode where they engage constantly in social comparison. They look at where their friends are having dinner and compare it to their own sad ball of microwave ramen noodles. They look at where their friends are honeymooning and think about their own lonely lives. They look at posts about the blue ribbon their friends daughter took home from the science fair and wonder why their own kids never make the honor roll. Being engaged in excessive social comparison decrease one's happiness. So it's not that you think that others are happier than you are, but you need to prove yourself to yourself over and over again, and
你评判自己，你比较自己是比你的朋友更好还是更差，我是不是更快乐，他们是不是更快乐，等等。奥哈德发现，花时间在社交媒体上会让人们进入一种不断进行社会比较的模式。他们看着朋友在哪里吃晚餐，然后将其与自己悲惨的一碗微波炉方便面进行比较。他们看着朋友在哪里度蜜月，然后想想自己孤独的生活。他们看着朋友的女儿从科学展上捧回蓝色缎带奖章的帖子，纳闷为什么自己的孩子从来没进过荣誉榜。参与过度的社会比较会降低一个人的幸福感。所以，并不是你认为别人比你更快乐，而是你需要一遍又一遍地向自己证明自己，
this social comparison engagement makes you less happy. At the University of Pennsylvania, psychologists Barbara Khan observed something similar. How students would often report that they were unhappy while they were off doing amazing things, attending a destination wedding or on a great vacation. Their Facebook feed told them that they were missing out on fun things that their friends were doing back home. What we found out from a lot of experiments that we ran, the thing that was generating the phomo, the feelings of fear of missing out.
这种参与社会比较的行为让你变得不那么快乐。在宾夕法尼亚大学，心理学家芭芭拉·康 (Barbara Kahn) 观察到了类似现象。学生们经常会报告说，当他们外出做一些了不起的事情（比如参加目的地婚礼或进行一次伟大的度假）时，他们其实并不快乐。他们的脸书动态告诉他们，他们错过了家里的朋友们正在进行的有趣活动。我们从进行的许多实验中发现，制造出 FOMO（错失恐惧症）的东西，
It isn't really a fear. It's like a social anxiety. And it's really more about what are your friends doing in building up their social group history that you're missing out on. So it's not really about the experience per se. In all of our experiments, we found that it was really more a function of an anxiety that something might happen in a group experience that will shape the group history in the future that you may not be part of, and that will undermine your group belongingness. And in fact, when we went back and said, okay, if you could make this decision again, would you choose to go to the beach weekend or to the wedding?
其实并不是一种恐惧。它更像是一种社交焦虑。它其实更多地关于你的朋友在建立他们的社交群体历史时，你错过了什么。所以这并不真的关乎体验本身。在我们所有的实验中，我们发现它更多地是一种焦虑功能的体现：即群体体验中可能会发生某些事情，这些事情将塑造未来的群体历史而你可能没有参与其中，从而会削弱你的群体归属感。事实上，当我们回过头去问：好吧，如果你能重新做出这个决定，你会选择去海滩周末还是去婚礼？
Although we didn't use that example in our studies, but that kind of thing, would you choose to go to the clearly better experience, or would you go to the routine thing your friends were doing on a regular basis? Almost every time people said, oh no, I'd go to the exotic event. It wasn't that they didn't think that the exotic event was better and the smarter decision. They had no regret about making that decision. What they were anxious about and we're using the word anxiety was that maybe something would happen in the group that would forever change the dynamics of the group and they wouldn't have been there when it happened.
虽然我们在研究中没有使用这个例子，但类似这样的事情，你会选择去那个明显更好的体验，还是去你朋友们经常去的那种常规事情？几乎每次人们都会说：“哦，不，我会去那个异国情调的活动。”并不是他们不认为异国情调的活动更好、更明智。他们对做出这个决定没有任何遗憾。让他们感到焦虑的是——我们用的是“焦虑”这个词——也许群体中会发生一些事情，永远改变群事情的动态，而事情发生时他们却不在场。
But sometimes seeing that others are doing things that you can't do or that others have what you don't have doesn't merely produce feelings of envy. It produces anger, resentment, as we saw with Homer Simpson. as we saw with Homer Simpson. No! When we come back, how a different kind of envy, sometimes called hostile envy, can lead to terrible consequences. The more hostile forms really have to do with leveling the playing field, not by bringing me up to where you are,
但有时看到别人在做你做不到的事，或者别人拥有你没有的东西，并不仅仅会产生嫉妒的感觉。它会产生愤怒、怨恨，正如我们在荷马·辛普森身上看到的那样。正如我们在荷马·辛普森身上看到的那样。不！当我们回来时，将探讨另一种有时被称为敌意嫉妒的嫉妒，如何会导致可怕的后果。更具敌意的情形实际上与拉平竞争环境有关，不是通过把你拉高到我的水平，
but rather bringing you down to where I am. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A topic today. I had time when I felt great. I was really envious.
而是把我拉低到你的水平。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。请继续收听。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们今天的主题。我曾有过感觉很好的时候。我真的很嫉妒。
So I was always an envy and I was still here. I did these feelings for a long time and it made me really kind of think that I was this terrible person. Envy and Shadon Freider. Psychologists, anthropologists, and primatologists have all studied how animals pay close attention to how well they are doing compared to their peers. In one classic study, Emory University primatologist Franz DeWall and his colleagues found that monkeys refused to do a task if they feel that other monkeys are getting a bigger reward than they get for the same task.
所以我总是处于嫉妒之中，而我依然留在这里。我带着这些感受很长时间，这让我真的有点认为自己是个糟糕的人。嫉妒与幸灾乐祸。心理学家、人类学家和灵长类动物学家都研究过动物如何密切关注自己与同伴相比表现如何。在经典研究中，埃默里大学的灵长类动物学家弗兰斯·德瓦尔 (Frans de Waal) 及其同事发现，如果猴子觉得其他猴子在完成相同的任务时得到了比它们更多的奖励，它们就会拒绝执行任务。
In another study conducted by researchers at the University of Zurich and the University of Nottingham, teams composed of two workers had their pay cut. In one case, both workers received the same pay cut. In another, only one worker received the pay cut, while the other salary remained unchanged. The researchers found that productivity declined more steeply when only one worker suffered a pay cut. The reason may feel intuitive. Workers were comparing their salary to those of their peers.
在苏黎世大学和诺丁汉大学的研究人员进行的另一项研究中，由两名工人组成的小组被削减了工资。在一种情况下，两名工人都受到了同等幅度的降薪。在另一种情况下，只有一名工人被降薪，而另一名工人的薪水保持不变。研究人员发现，当只有一名工人遭遇降薪时，生产力的下降更为明显。原因可能很直观：工人们在将自己的薪水与同伴的薪水进行比较。
When everyone suffered a pay cut, it didn't make them feel good, but it didn't make them feel envious because everyone was in the same boat. When only one person suffered a pay cut, there was instant envy. We can all understand and empathize with this form of envy, but it can be harder for us to confront in unclear form. What sociologists sometimes call malicious envy. What's interesting and sad is that we reserve this kind of envy for our neighbors, classmates, friends, our peers.
当所有人都遭遇降薪时，这不会让他们感觉良好，但这不会让他们感到嫉妒，因为每个人都在同一条船上。当只有一个人遭遇降薪时，瞬间的嫉妒就产生了。我们都能理解并感同身受这种形式的嫉妒，但对于那种不太清晰的形式，我们可能更难去面对。这就是社会学家有时所说的恶意嫉妒。有趣又悲哀的是，我们将这种嫉妒留给了我们的邻居、同学、朋友和同伴。
Here are social psychologists, Mina Chikara. People pick relevant comparison standards on relevant dimensions. So those are two key ingredients and that's an extremely important point. Colleges, Meena Chicara. People pick relevant comparison standards on relevant dimensions. So those are two key ingredients and that's an extremely important point. I'm not going to compare my salary, say, to Warren Buffett. I'm going to compare it to another assistant professor in my department or at another university in the same department. So again, ironically, then, the most virulent forms of envy are reserved for people in
这里是社会心理学家梅娜·奇卡拉。人们会在相关的维度上选择相关的比较标准。所以这是两个关键因素，这是一个极其重要的点。大学里的梅娜·奇卡拉。人们会在相关的维度上选择相关的比较标准。所以这是两个关键因素，这是一个极其重要的点。我不会把我的薪水拿去和沃伦·巴菲特作比较。我会把它和我们系里或同一所大学另一个系里的另一位助理教授作比较。所以再次讽刺的是，最毒辣的嫉妒恰恰留给了在
some ways who are in the same boat as us. That's exactly right. Once malicious or hostile envy is aroused within us, it's an easy leap to Shadon Freider. When the targets of our envy stumble and fall, we cheer. Hostile envy might know at you, but Shadon Freider feels pleasurable. It soothes the pain of envy. This push and pull fascinates Richard Smith. Richard is extensively researched and written about both kinds of envy. Among the books he's authored is one on Shadon Freider called
某些方面和我们同在一条船上的人。完全正确。一旦恶意或敌意的嫉妒在我们心中被唤醒，迈向幸灾乐祸就是轻而易举的事。当我们嫉妒的目标绊倒并跌倒时，我们就会欢呼。敌意的嫉妒可能会折磨你，但幸灾乐祸却能带来快乐。它舒缓了嫉妒的痛苦。这种推拉深深吸引了理查德·斯密斯 (Richard Smith)。理查德对这两种嫉妒都进行了广泛的研究并撰写了相关文章。他撰写的书籍中包括一本关于幸灾乐祸的书，名为
the Joy of Pain. Richard's always on the lookout for good examples of envy and shardonnful writer. One of his favorites is from the 1984 Academy Award-winning movie, Amadeus. It's about the Italian composer Antonio Salieri and its complicated feelings toward a pure and fellow composer. Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart. Mozart. In fact, as the movie opens, Salieri is at the top of his game. He's one of the most influential figures in European music and the official composer to the Habsburg court. His future is bright until Mozart arrives on the scene. Salieri is eager to meet the young man.
《痛苦的快乐》(The Joy of Pain)。理查德一直在寻找嫉妒和幸灾乐祸的好例子。他最喜欢的例子之一来自1984年获得奥斯卡奖的电影《莫扎特传》(Amadeus)。电影讲述了意大利作曲家安东尼奥·萨利耶里 (Antonio Salieri) 及其对纯粹的同行作曲家沃尔夫冈·阿马德乌斯·莫扎特 (Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart) 的复杂情感。莫扎特。事实上，当电影开场时，萨利耶里正处于事业的巅峰。他是欧洲音乐界最有影响力的人物之一，也是哈布斯堡宫廷的官方作曲家。他的未来一片光明，直到莫扎特出现在大众视野中。萨利耶里急于见到这个年轻人。
As I wanted through this salon, I played a little game with myself. Salieri is eager Mozart is coarse and loud. The first time Salieri sees Mozart, the musical genius is groping a young woman, his hand stuffed down her blouse. Salieri is disgusted, he's envious. Why he asks himself, has God given such a dirty-minded creature such talent? Soon enough, Salieri has his opportunity to pull Mozart off his pedestal. My favorite scene in the movie is that kind of
当我穿过这个沙龙时，我跟自己玩了个小游戏。萨利耶里渴望莫扎特粗俗而吵闹。萨利耶里第一次见到莫扎特时，这位音乐天才正在对一个年轻女性动手动脚，他的手塞进了她的衬衫里。萨利耶里感到恶心，他感到嫉妒。他问自己，为什么上帝会把如此思想肮脏的生物赋予这样的才华？很快，萨利耶里就迎来了把莫扎特拉下神坛的机会。我最喜欢电影中的那个场景，
captures the envy is when Mozart's wife comes to Salieri. I've come on behalf of my husband. I've brought on behalf of my husband. I've brought you some samples of his work so that you can be considered for the royal appointment. At first, Salieri sort of pretends as if he wants to help. I will look at them, of course, the moment I can. Would it be too much trouble, sir,
捕捉到了这种嫉妒，当时莫扎特的妻子来到了萨利耶里这里。我是代表我丈夫来的。我是代表我丈夫来的。我带了他的一些作品样本给你，好让你能考虑皇室的任命。起初，萨利耶里假装他想帮忙。当然，我一有空就会看它们的。先生，能不能麻烦你
to ask you to look at them now? I'm afraid I'm not at pleasure. This precise moment. Just leave them with me. I assure you,'m not at pleasure. This precise moment. Just leave them with me. I assure you they will be quite safe. I really cannot do that, sir. You see, he doesn't know I'm here. Then he didn't send you?
现在就看一看？恐怕我现在没空。此时此刻。只要把它们留在我这儿。我向你保证，我现在没空。此时此刻。只要把它们留在我这儿。我向你保证，它们会非常安全。我真的不能那样做，先生。你看，他不知道我在这儿。那么他没有派你来？
No, sir. This was my own idea. We're desperate. We really need this job. Then he has the machine music. And he gets up and looks at it. Both gang would be frantic if he found those were missing. You see, they're all originals.
不，先生。这完全是我自己的主意。我们走投无路了。我们真的很需要这份工作。然后他拿到了曲谱。他站起来看着它。如果沃尔夫冈发现这些不见了，他会疯掉的。你看，这些全都是原稿。
And it's one done wonderful in the film. These are originals? Mm-hmm. You hear him imagining the music in his head because he's a musician who he can look at the notes and hear the music. He's also talking in the background. Music. Finish does no music is ever finished.
电影里这一段做得太棒了。这些都是原稿？嗯哼。你听到他在脑海中想象着音乐，因为他是一位音乐家，他可以看着音符就听到音乐。他还在背景中说话。音乐完成了，没有任何音乐是真正完成的。
The music finished as no music is ever finished. This place one note, and they would be the finishment. This place one phrase and the structure would fall. Then the way the film shows it, you see see his face and it's in pain. So the thing that's very, it's very, very moving and very beautiful about this is also the idea that Salieri is someone who actually is talented enough to actually appreciate what it is that Mozart can do, that he actually can look at that sheet music and hear the music come to life,
音乐完成了，没有任何音乐是真正完成的。只要弹错一个音符，一切就都完了。只要弹错一个乐句，整个结构就会坍塌。然后电影展现这一幕的方式是，你看他的表情，充满了痛苦。所以，非常、非常感人且美丽的一点还在于，萨利耶里其实是一个才华足够高、能够真正欣赏莫扎特所作所为的人，他真的能够看着那张乐谱并听到音乐活过来，
which obviously most people would not be able to do. I suppose you could say that enhances that sense of core similarity in a way. I mean, he knows what it is that he's appreciating. That's part of the pain that intimate knowledge. The pain is too much, and the only thing that would relieve it is the joy Salieri imagines he will feel when Mozart is destroyed. And that is exactly what happens.
显然绝大多数人是做不到这一点的。我想你可以说这在某种程度上增强了那种核心相似感。我的意思是，他知道他正在欣赏的是什么。这种深刻的了解正是痛苦的一部分。痛苦太深了，唯一能缓解它的，就是萨利耶里想象中当莫扎特毁灭时他会感受到的快乐。而这正是发生的事情。
Salieri becomes the architect of Mozart's downfall. He watches with pleasure as the younger composer succumbs to overwork and dies, penniless and desperate. In our modern lives, there are endless examples of this kind of envy. You have an obligation. You have an obligation to walk wholly and to walk righteous and to walk pure before God. In the 1980s, Jimmy Swaggart was one of the most popular TV evangelists in the United States.
萨利耶里成为了莫扎特垮台的策划者。他幸灾乐祸地看着这位年轻的作曲家因过度劳累而屈服，身无分文且绝望地死去。在我们现代的生活中，这种嫉妒的例子数不胜数。你有一项义务。你有一项义务要在上帝面前完全、公义、纯洁地行走。在20世纪80年代，吉米·斯瓦格特 (Jimmy Swaggart) 是美国最受欢迎的电视布道家之一。
He described himself as God's messenger. But I'm going to preach what I believe this word says. Our bodies are temples of the Holy Spirit. We are personifications of the Lord Jesus Christ. We are supposed to be examples of righteousness. Sw I got said, there was no room for moral compromise. Our church in Baton Rouge, Louisiana the other day, we just started a ball team and I told them, I said, if girls show up on that ball dam and with shorts on, I will appreciate you and do everything I can to help you in Jesus, but I'll send you home to get some clothes on.
他把自己描述为上帝的使者。但我打算宣讲我相信这本圣经所说的话。我们的身体是圣灵的殿。我们是主耶稣基督的化身。我们理应成为公义的榜样。斯瓦格特说，道德妥协没有容身之地。前几天我们在路易斯安那州巴吞鲁日的教堂，我们刚刚组建了一支球队，我对他们说，我说，如果女孩们穿着短裤出现在球场上，我会感激你们并尽一切努力在主里帮助你们，但我会送你们回家换上衣服。
But Swagged apparently had trouble keeping his own clothes on. It came out that he was involved with a prostitute, sometimes meeting her for trists at a rundown motel. Swagged confessed on his national TV broadcast. I have sinned against you, my lord. And I would ask that your precious blood would wash and cleanse every stain. Many of Swagged's followers were devastated, but plenty of his critics crowed with delight.
但斯瓦格特显然管不住自己的裤腰带。后来爆出他与一名妓女有染，有时还在破旧的汽车旅馆里与她幽会。斯瓦格特在全国电视直播中供认不讳。我得罪了你，我的主。我请求你宝贵的血能够洗净并涤荡每一个污点。斯瓦格特的许多追随者心碎不已，但他的许多批评者却幸灾乐祸地欢呼雀跃。
There was no need to even hide the Shadon Freude because after all, Swagart was a hypocrite. He had gotten rich preaching righteousness while using his money to sin. Mina Chikara says it was in fact, a perfect recipe for Shadan Khriday. So if a person has ill-gotten gains and those gains then get taken away from them, we feel pleasure. In large part, you know, again here we're not benefiting ourselves, but we feel good because some justice has been done. There is some, some karmic restoration has taken place. In fact, in a TV interview, even the sex worker he'd been caught with Debra Mourphry felt he'd gotten his just desserts. He's up there crying and now little tears aren't real.
甚至不需要隐藏幸灾乐祸，因为毕竟，斯瓦格特是个伪君子。他靠宣讲公义发了财，却用他的钱去犯罪。梅娜·奇卡拉说，这实际上是幸灾乐祸的绝佳配方。所以，如果一个人通过不正当手段获得了利益，而这些利益随后被夺走了，我们就会感到快乐。很大程度上，你知道，这里我们并不是在让自己受益，但我们感到高兴，因为某种正义得到了伸张。某种因果报应得到了恢复。事实上，在一次电视采访中，甚至连那个与他有染被抓包的性工作者黛布拉·莫菲 (Debra Murphy) 也觉得他罪有应得。他在那里哭泣，现在眼泪都不是真的。
How do you know? This can be, I mean because he was up there preaching about all this stuff and then time doing it. Not surprisingly Jimmy Spaggert's downfall proved irresistible for those who thrive on Charter Friday. Late Night Com comedians. Now in the Reverend Dr. Carl Pethos, this ministry's spiritual gana college. Mina and Richard point out that hypocrisy often triggers Shadon Freude. But it's often not the only spark of this emotion. We tend to feel pleasure when people
你怎么知道？这可以，我的意思是，因为他在那里宣讲所有这些事情，然后自己却在做。毫不奇怪，对于那些靠幸灾乐祸维生的人来说，吉米·斯瓦格特的垮台简直有着不可抗拒的吸引力。深夜脱口秀喜剧演员。现在，在卡尔·佩索斯牧师 (Rev. Dr. Carl Pethos) 博士手下，这个事工的精神加纳学院。梅娜和理查德指出，伪善往往会引发幸灾乐祸。但这通常不是这种情绪的唯一火花。当那些
who get too big for their bridges get taken down a peg. Too big for their bridges, or to put it another way. The cutting down of tall poppies. The cutting down of tall poppies. These are not just the hypocrites, but people who are also too greedy, too rich, but also perhaps too nice, too smart, too pretty, too successful. Hello and welcome to Martha Stewart Living. I'm so glad you could join us today. nice, too smart, too pretty, too successful. Hello and welcome to Martha Stewart Living. I'm so glad you could join us today. We have a program filled with great ideas
尾巴翘得太高的人被敲打一番时，我们往往会感到快乐。尾巴翘得太高，或者换句话说。修剪高大的罂粟花。修剪高大的罂粟花。这些不只是伪君子，还有那些太贪婪、太富有的人，但也可能是太友善、太聪明、太漂亮、太成功的人。你好，欢迎收看《玛莎·斯图尔特生活》(Martha Stewart Living)。很高兴今天你能加入我们。友善、太聪明、太漂亮、太成功。你好，欢迎收看《玛莎·斯图尔特生活》。很高兴今天你能加入我们。我们为您准备了一个充满好点子
and very interesting projects. In 2004, Martha Stewart was accused of insider trading. A jury in New York convicted Martha Stewart today on all four counts against her in the Imclone stock case. She was charged with love. After her sentence was announced, it was open season for Martha and prison Chardonn for Eida. Martha Stewart.
和非常有趣项目的节目。2004年，玛莎·斯图尔特被指控内幕交易。纽约的一个陪审团今天裁定玛莎·斯图尔特在Imclone股票案中被控的四项罪名全部成立。她被指控做假。在她的宣判宣布后，对玛莎的审判和监狱幸灾乐祸进入了公开阶段。玛莎·斯图尔特。
Inside Trader and CEO Hope. Sentence 30 years. Hello, everyone. You love me. So fresh. You love me. What's up, baby? I've made us some decorative name tags out of birch barks
内幕交易员兼CEO希望。判刑30年。大家好。你们爱我。如此新鲜。你们爱我。怎么了，宝贝？我用桦树皮做了一些装饰性的名牌，
so we could get to know each other better. Why did such pleasure in the downfall of Martha Stewart? She was an all-American success story, someone who turned her passion for beautiful things into a business empire. Why not celebrate a success like that? She's an interesting case. The way I see it is that in a way she was too good at too many things, even though at least the way she would present herself as someone who was doing things to help people, it's just the sum total would have a cumulative effect of just too much. She was too tall a puppy.
这样我们就能更好地了解彼此。为什么对玛莎·斯图尔特的垮台会产生如此的快乐？她是一个全美式的成功故事，一个将自己对美好事物的热情转化为商业帝国的人。为什么不为这样的成功庆贺呢？她是一个有趣的案例。在我看来，某种程度上她是在太多事情上都表现得太优秀了，尽管至少从她展现自己的方式来看，她是一个在做事情帮助别人的人，但这一切的总和会产生一种“好得过头”的累积效应。她是一株太高的罂粟花。
Martha Stewart herself recognized that she got on the people's skin. She acknowledged this much to now former NBC anchor Matt Lauer in an interview after her release from prison. You're a magnet for praise and sometimes criticism. Oh, it's sort of equally. Do you think it's 50-50? I think it's sometimes much worse and it's and I don't understand it. I write books. I publish beautiful magazines. I've done television shows that are devoted to how to and good living. Why do you think people criticize you then?
玛莎·斯图尔特本人也意识到她有些招人厌烦。她在出狱后接受前NBC主播马特·劳尔 (Matt Lauer) 的采访时，对此供认不讳。你是赞美的磁石，有时也是批评的磁石。哦，这大致是平分秋色的。你觉得是五五开吗？我觉得有时情况要糟糕得多，而且我不理解。我写书。我出版美丽的杂志。我做过致力于教人如何生活和过上好日子的电视节目。那你觉得为什么人们还要批评你呢？
I don't know. I don't know. I'm just maybe because I'm confident. I think sometimes maybe I'm too confident. Maybe I should have failed and maybe I should have just gone away and dug a hole and jumped in. I, you know, who knows? Well Richard Smith knows a bit and he believes humans have evolved to resent those who outperform us. If you look at the words that we have available in our language for, say, feeling happy over someone's success, I actually can't think of any, not a single word. You have to sort of add other words to kind of clarify what kind of happiness you're having. Though envy, we do have words for envy and resentment
我不知道。我不知道。我只是，也许是因为我很自信。我想有时也许我太自信了。也许我应该失败，也许我应该直接走开，挖个洞跳进去。我，你知道，谁知道呢？好吧，理查德·斯密斯知道一些，他相信人类已经进化到会去怨恨那些表现优于我们的人。如果你看看我们的语言中用来表达，比如说，为某人的成功感到高兴的词汇，我其实想不出一个，一个都没有。你必须加上其他词来澄清你拥有的是哪种快乐。尽管对于嫉妒，我们确实有嫉妒和怨恨
and so forth. So I don't think it's so natural for us to feel happy for other success, just all other things being equal. Primatologist Christopher Bohm has noticed similar behavior in his studies of hunter-gatherer tribes. These groups are extremely vigilant to the person who gets too big for his bridges. They may criticize him if it gets too bad, they may ostracize him, if it really gets too bad, they'll kill him. When others are doing fabulously better than we are, our instinct is to pull them down,
之类的词。所以我认为，在一切条件相同的情况下，我们很难自然而然地为别人的成功感到高兴。灵长类动物学家克里斯托弗·博姆在对狩猎采集部落的研究中也注意到了类似的行为。这些群体对那些尾巴翘得太高的人保持着极高的警惕。如果情况变得太糟，他们可能会批评他；如果真的糟透了，他们可能会排挤他；如果实在不可收拾，他们就会杀了他。当别人表现得比我们好得多时，我们的本能就是把他们拉下来，
closer to where we are. When that happens, when they fall, well, it feels good. Of course, Martha Stewart and Jimmy Swagger are both anecdotes. Our feelings toward them haven't been measured in any scientifically valid way. It turns out envy and shard and friday are very hard to study. Most people know it's wise to hide these negative emotions. When we come back, measuring these unsimly emotions in the lab. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we open the pantry and devour a box of cookies, we usually hide the evidence. When we fantasize about winning the lottery and hoarding the cash, or imagine flipping the desk of our most irritating colleague, we tuck those emotions away.
拉到更接近我们水平的地方。当这种情况发生时，当他们跌倒时，嗯，感觉很好。当然，玛莎·斯图尔特和吉米·斯瓦格特都只是轶事。我们对他们的感受并未以任何科学有效的方式进行衡量。事实证明，嫉妒和幸灾乐祸非常难以研究。大多数人都知道隐藏这些负面情绪是明智之举。当我们回来时，将探讨如何在实验室里衡量这些难登大雅之堂的情绪。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当我们打开食品储藏室狼吞虎咽地吃完一盒饼干时，我们通常会把证据藏起来。当我们幻想中彩票并将现金据为己有，或者想象掀翻我们最讨厌的同事的办公桌时，我们会把这些情绪藏进心底。
Gluttony, greed, wrath. We don't want to expose them to the light of day. But envy and its wicked cousin, Shadon Freude, these may be the emotions we bury the deepest. You know, I think we all know, we all learn very early on, that we're not supposed to express pleasure and response to other people's misfortunes. Now, there's another perhaps less overt reason to do that, is that once you express shot in Florida, it demonstrates that you were feeling envious of that person in the first place. And so one of the problems with expressing envy, of course, is that you have to admit outwardly that you understand that you are inferior on some dimension. And who wants to do that? Of course, as with most things in life, there are some exceptions, times when it's okay
暴食、贪婪、愤怒。我们不想把它们暴露在光天化日之下。但嫉妒及其邪恶的表亲——幸灾乐祸，这些可能是我们埋藏得最深的情绪。你知道，我想我们都知道，我们很早就学会了，我们不应该表现出对他人不幸的快乐回应。现在，还有另一个不那么公开的原因这样做，那就是一旦你表现出幸灾乐祸，这就证明你从一开始就对那个人感到嫉妒。因此，表达嫉妒的问题之一，当然是你在表面上必须承认，你在某些维度上不如对方。谁又想这样做呢？当然，正如生活中的大多数事情一样，也有一些例外，有些时候表现出
to express such emotions. Politics is one. Celebrity gossip is a second, and sports is a third. And so it's these areas, especially sports, that social scientists have honed in on in their efforts to study envy and shard and freedom. Coach K and the Duke Blue Devils against Coach Cal and the Kentucky Wildcats early on. Richard Smith and colleagues are the University of Kentucky. Put together a study on basketball rivalry between the Kentucky Wildcats and the Duke Blue Devils.
这种情绪是可以接受的。政治是一个，名人八卦是第二个，体育是第三个。正是这些领域，尤其是体育，成为了社会科学研究嫉妒和幸灾乐祸的发力点。K教练和杜克蓝魔队对阵卡尔教练和肯塔基野猫队，早期。理查德·斯密斯和肯塔基大学的同事们。针对肯塔基野猫队和杜克蓝魔队之间的篮球宿敌情结开展了一项研究。
Now, obviously Kentucky fans experience a type of Shadon Freude when the Blue Devils lose. But what the researchers wanted to know was whether Shadon Freude led to more sinister places. So the asked University of Kentucky students to respond anonymously to an article describing an injury to the star player on the rival Duke team. What they found is that students who didn't care about basketball felt no shot in Freud and considerable sympathy for the injured player. Hardcore Kentucky fans, however, had an entirely different reaction.
现在，显然当蓝魔队输球时，肯塔基队的球迷会体验到一种幸灾乐祸。但研究人员想要知道的是，幸灾乐祸是否会导致更险恶的境地。因此，他们要求肯塔基大学的学生匿名回复一篇文章，该文章描述了敌对杜克队明星球员受伤的事件。他们发现，不关心篮球的学生没有表现出幸灾乐祸，反而对受伤的球员表现出相当多的同情。然而，狂热的肯塔基球迷却有着完全不同的反应。
These fans were happy when a rival player got seriously injured. Shardin Freud, in other words, is such a powerful emotion that it can make us feel good when a rival suffers serious physical harm. Mina Chikara wanted to know what exactly was happening inside the brain when a fan feels the pleasure of Shardin Freude. So she did a study looking at baseball fans. Red Sox and Yankees fans to participate in our study. And so the idea here was that we would recruit these hardcore Red Sox and Yankees fans and they would see baseball plays unfolding while they were lying in the functional MRI machine. Mina was interested in a part of the brain that's activated when a person is experiencing pleasure. And so we had these
这些粉丝在竞争对手的球员受重伤时感到高兴。换句话说，幸灾乐祸（Schadenfreude）是一种如此强大的情绪，以至于当竞争对手遭受严重的身体伤害时，它能让我们感觉良好。Mina Chikara想知道，当粉丝感受到幸灾乐祸的快乐时，大脑内部究竟发生了什么。于是她做了一项针对棒球迷的研究。红袜队和洋基队的球迷参与了我们的研究。这里的想法是，我们招募这些核心的红袜队和洋基队员，当他们躺在功能性磁共振机器中时，他们会观看展开的棒球比赛。Mina对大脑中当一个人体验快乐时被激活的部分很感兴趣。所以我们让这些
participants, these Red Sox and Yankees fans watching these plays and folding the scanner and after each play we asked them how good they felt about the play and how bad they felt about the play and what we found was that participants not only they felt the most pleasure when their own team did well particularly against their rivals but they also the most pleasure when their own team did well, particularly against their rivals, but they also felt more pleasure than a control condition when they saw their rival fail even against a third party team. And the idea here is that there's no material benefit to your own team.
参与者，这些红袜队和洋基队的球迷在扫描仪中观看这些比赛的展开，在每场比赛结束后，我们问他们对这场比赛感觉有多好，对这场比赛感觉有多坏，我们发现的是，参与者不仅在他们自己的球队表现好时感到最快乐，特别是针对他们的竞争对手时，而且当他们自己的球队表现好时，他们也感到最快乐，特别是针对他们的竞争对手，但当他们看到竞争对手失败时，即使是对阵第三方球队，他们也比对照条件感到更多的快乐。这里的想法是，对你自己的球队没有任何物质上的好处。
So if you're a Red Sox fan and you see the Yankees get tagged out at the end of one play, there's no material or actual benefit to use Red Sox. You could make the argument, you know, it might change league standings, but we were always showing participants plays from the very beginning of a game where it couldn't determine the outcome of a game and therefore each team's respective league standings.
所以，如果你是一个红袜队的球迷，你看到洋基队在一场比赛结束时被出局，对你红袜队来说没有任何物质或实际的好处。你可以争辩说，你知道，它可能会改变联盟的排名，但我们总是向参与者展示比赛刚开始时的比赛，这无法决定比赛的结果，因此也无法决定各个球队各自的联盟排名。
And the idea is that the reason this is pleasure is driven solely by the rivalry. You haven't benefited materially in any way. You only feel pleasure because it feels good to watch a rival fail. In another study, Mina and her colleagues tried to measure Schadenfreider by analyzing muscle movements in the face. We've used something called facial electromiography, whereby we place electrodes on the main muscles of the face and we measure specifically from the cheek muscles because those are the muscles that pull your lips into a smile and
这个想法是，这种快乐的原因完全是由竞争驱动的。你在任何方面都没有在物质上受益。你只会感到快乐，因为看着竞争对手失败感觉很好。在另一项研究中，Mina和她的同事试图通过分析面部肌肉运动来测量幸灾乐祸。我们使用了被称为面部肌电图的技术，我们在脸部的主要肌肉上放置电极，我们专门测量脸颊肌肉，因为这些是将你的嘴唇拉成微笑的肌肉，并且
engagement of that muscle is very reliably related to people feeling pleasure. Now it can't tell us the difference between happy pure unadulterated joy and shot-in for ito which is this more malicious form of pleasure but it can tell us that there's some positive affect being felt, or it suggests that there's some positive affect being felt. So we've used that as an indicator of Shadunfreudeau when people are exposed to target suffering of misfortune. If I remember correctly, you can access study ones where you evaluated how people were reacting to various people in various situations,
该肌肉的参与与人们感到快乐非常可靠地相关。现在它无法告诉我们纯粹的、未经掺杂的快乐与幸灾乐祸之间的区别，后者是这种更具恶意的快乐形式，但它可以告诉我们正在感受到一些积极的情感，或者它表明正在感受到一些积极的情感。因此，当人们暴露在目标遭受不幸时，我们将其用作幸灾乐祸的指标。如果我没记错的话，你可以访问第一项研究，在那里你评估了人们对各种情况下各种人的反应，
for people getting soaked as a taxi drove through a puddle. And some of those experiments sort of utilize these same measurement techniques. Exactly. So for example, one of our arguments, one of the questions that we asked ourselves was, which groups tend to be the envied groups? You know, people respond with less empathy to all sorts of out groups. And when I say out group, I just mean groups to which I do not belong. But not all out groups are equivalent. So for example, if I saw an elderly man get splashed by a taxi driving past him,
比如当出租车驶过水坑时，人们被淋湿了。其中一些实验使用了这些相同的测量技术。完全正确。所以，例如，我们的一个论点，我们问自己的一个问题是，哪些群体往往是受嫉妒的群体？你知道，人们对各种外群体的同理心较少。当我说外群体时，我只是指我不属于的群体。但并非所有外群体都是对等的。例如，如果我看到一个老汉被开过他身边的出租车溅湿了，
I don't think I would feel any pleasure. But if I saw Bernie made off getting splashed by a taxi, I'd feel all sorts of pleasure, right? And the idea is that people feel bad when bad things happen to people for whom they feel pride or people for whom they feel pity, like the elderly, they even feel bad when bad things happen to homeless and drug addicted individuals. The only time that they feel good,
我想我不会感到任何快乐。但如果我看到伯尼·麦道夫被出租车溅湿，我会感到各种各样的快乐，对吧？这个想法是，当坏事发生在那些让他们感到自豪的人或他们感到同情的人（如老年人）身上时，人们会感到难过，当坏事发生在无家可归者和吸毒成瘾者身上时，他们甚至会感到难过。他们唯一一次感觉良好的时候，
when a bad thing happens is to those groups again, that are seen as competitive and high status in society. So that's wealthy individuals, business people, and so on. Part of what's interesting about this research is that it's looking at brain responses like pleasure and pain that are quite primal. They may have helped hunter-gatherers form strong tribal identities, but for modern humans, these neurological responses might have a downside. Now, one of the things that we were interested in in large part inspired by some of the work by Richard Smith and his colleagues was whether or not this pleasure response that people self-reported was related to a desire to harm the rival team and associated individuals.
当坏事发生时，是针对那些再次被视为社会中具有竞争力和高地位的群体。也就是富人、商界人士等等。这项研究有趣的部分原因在于，它着眼于像快乐和痛苦这样相当原始的大脑反应。它们可能曾帮助狩猎采集者形成强烈的部落认同，但对于现代人类来说，这些神经反应可能会有消极面。现在，我们感兴趣的一点很大程度上受到理查德·史密斯及其同事的一些工作的启发，即人们自我报告的这种快乐反应是否与伤害竞争对手球队及相关个人的愿望有关。
In the MRIs of the baseball fans, Mina discovered that those who reported the most pleasure at watching their rival fail were also the people who had the most activation in a small part of the brain known as the ventral striator. So with that in mind, Mina followed up. So two weeks after we scanned them, we sent all of our participants a web survey where we asked them how likely they would be to engage in a variety of aggressive behaviors. And the thing that we found that was really exciting for us as academics, but probably bad for the world, was that those people who exhibited that much more ventral straddle activity when watching their rival fail two weeks earlier in the scanner
在棒球迷的MRI中，Mina发现，那些报告在看竞争对手失败时感到最多快乐的人，也是大脑中被称为腹侧纹状体的小部分激活最多的人。带着这个想法，Mina进行了跟进。因此，在我们扫描他们两周后，我们向所有参与者发送了一份网络调查，询问他们参与各种攻击性行为的可能性有多大。我们发现的对我们作为学者来说非常兴奋，但对世界来说可能很糟糕的事情是，那些在两周前在扫描仪中观看竞争对手失败时表现出更多腹侧纹状体活动的人
were the same people who then told us they would be that much more likely to threaten, heckle, and hit a rival fan. In other words, the amount of pleasure you take in a rival's failure is a potent predictor of how far you might take matters into your own heads. What do you do if you, in fact, envy another group? And if it's a malicious form of envy and it reminds one of one's inferiority, one solution to that is to find ways to eliminate that source of one's inferiority, one solution to that is to find ways to eliminate that source of one's envy. Eliminate the source of one's envy.
正是那些后来告诉我们他们更有可能威胁、起哄和殴打竞争对手球迷的人。换句话说，你在竞争对手的失败中获得的快乐程度，是你能把事情推向多远的一个强有力的预测指标。如果你事实上嫉妒另一个群体，你该怎么办？如果这是一种恶意的嫉妒，让人想起自己的劣势，解决方案之一就是找到方法来消除这种劣势的根源，解决方案之一就是找到方法来消除这种劣势的根源。消除嫉妒的根源。
Maybe that happens by accident when a rival team's star player blows out a knee. But Richard says it could also be an active cutting down of an envied group. In fact, he believes that malicious envy and shard and fraud may have been one of the underlying triggers of the Holocaust. The suffering of Jews in the 1930s and 1940s came after a time of Jewish prosperity when many average Germans were struggling financially. If you look at a lot of the history of Jews in Germany, also in Austria, they were very, very successful and in a way were disproportionate successful in many areas of German life.
也许这在竞争对手球队的明星球员十字韧带撕裂时偶然发生，但理查德说，这也可能是对受嫉妒群体的积极削减。事实上，他认为恶意的嫉妒和幸灾乐祸可能是大屠杀的潜在诱因之一。20世纪30年代和40年代犹太人的苦难发生在一个犹太人繁荣时期之后，当时许多普通德国人在经济上苦苦挣扎。如果你看看犹太人在德国以及奥地利的许多历史，他们非常非常成功，并在某种程度上在德国生活的许多领域取得了不成比例的成功。
Richard's theory is that this may have spawned malicious envy among some Germans. This envy was then spurred on by Nazi propaganda. Along the way, of course, Nazis did various things before they engineered the final solution. But any time Jews suffered in some way, either because of things that the Nazis did deliberately to engineer it like Kristallnacht and so forth, would be satisfying in that sense if one understands how envy would produce that type of reaction the first place. And if you have enough experiences of feeling good when someone suffers or some group suffers, then the next step in a sense is to actually literally engineer fully. Sometimes, however, there is nothing we can do
理查德的理论是，这可能在一些德国人中催生了恶意的嫉妒。这种嫉妒随后被纳粹宣传所刺激。当然，在此过程中，纳粹在策划最终解决方案之前做了各种事情。但如果人们理解嫉妒最初是如何产生这种反应的，那么犹太人以某种方式遭受痛苦的任何时候，无论是由于纳粹故意策划的事情，如水晶之夜等等，在这个意义上都是令人满意的。如果你有足够的体验，当某人遭受痛苦或某个群体遭受痛苦时感觉良好，那么从某种意义上说，下一步就是真正字面意义上完全策划。然而，有时我们无能为力
to pull down those above us. They're too powerful, too distant. That's when Mina and Richard think our insecurities find a different outlet. There's a very strong psychological impulse to avoid being placed in the last place. That is, last place aversion, this idea that as long as you can look down and see that there's at least another person or another group beneath you, there's comfort from which
来拉低我们上面的人。他们太强大，太遥远了。那是Mina和Richard认为我们的不安全感找到不同出口的时候。有一种非常强烈的心理冲动，即避免被置于最后一名。也就是说，最后一名厌恶，这种想法是，只要你能向下看，看到至少还有另一个人或另一个群体在你之下，你就能从中获得安慰
you can derive from knowing that information. So one of the interesting things that people often bring up is this paradox whereby poor people will oftentimes support policies that are bad for them. And in one of the potential arguments for explaining why that is is not because you don't necessarily have to appeal to some broader idea about belief in a just world or everybody gets what they want. It's it's it's a simply just last place a version. So these policies don't they may be bad for me in some immediate sense. They're at least maintaining some hierarchical structures so that I don't end up at the very bottom.
你可以通过了解这些信息得出结论。因此，人们经常提出的有趣事情之一是这种悖论，即穷人往往会支持对他们不利的政策。解释为什么会这样的潜在论点之一，不是因为你不一定必须诉诸关于相信公正世界的更广泛想法或每个人都得到了他们想要的东西。它简单地就是最后一名厌恶。所以这些政策并没有，它们可能在某种直接意义上对我有害。它们至少在维持一些等级结构，这样我就不会最终落入最底层。
Anytime someone's doing worse than us in any kind of way, there is a potential, okay, that's good. I'm not as bad as they are. And especially if some reason we're needing a boost because we have some insecurities, whatever case may be, then that down comparison is a more of a potential boost. There are studies to back this up, but Richard likes to use an example of the one's popular reality TV show to catch a predator. They're online and on the prowl, grown men targeting children on the internet.
每当有人在任何方面比我们做得差时，都有可能，好吧，这很好。我没有他们那么糟糕。特别是如果由于某种原因我们需要提振，因为我们有一些不安全感，无论情况如何，那么向下的比较就更有可能是潜在的提振。有研究支持这一点，但理查德喜欢用一个曾经流行的真人秀节目《捉捕恶魔》（To Catch a Predator）的例子。他们在网上寻找目标，成年男性在互联网上以儿童为目标。
The show features undercover sting operations in which people pose as underage youth. When adult men contact the decoys over the internet, looking for sexual liaisons, they're with cameras rolling. Those guys that were part of that sting, nobody could see themselves as a down comparison compared to them. I mean, this is the lowest to the lowest. So if you wanted to find someone who could really say, what a low life, and I'm certain it's not like that, I may not be doing well in all these kinds of ways. I may not be unemployed, I may be this, I may that, but I am not showing
该节目以卧底钓鱼执法行动为特色，其中人们冒充未成年青少年。当成年男性通过互联网联系诱饵寻求性接触时，他们的镜头正在滚动。参与那次钓鱼执法的那些家伙，没有人能把自己看作与他们相比的向下比较。我的意思是，这是最底层的底层。所以如果你想找一个真正能说，真是一个人渣的人，我确信不是这样的，我可能在所有这些方面都做得不好。我可能失业了，我可能是这个，我可能是那个，但我没有露面
up to see an underage person. Our pleasure in seeing people fall below us, allowed for behavior on the show that most of us would find unacceptable in other situations. So much so that the producers of that show could humiliate these men in a very extreme way, in a way that you couldn't imagine doing to somebody else and feel good about it, but there's almost no guilt, humiliation of another human being, and quite the opposite. The viewer is probably getting a lot out of it. I just wanted to talk. I swear to you, you know, if you...
来看一个未成年人。我们在看到人们落于我们之下时感到的快乐，允许了该节目中我们大多数人在其他情况下会认为不可接受的行为。以至于该节目的制作人可以以一种极端的方式羞辱这些男人，这种方式你无法想象对其他人这样做并感觉良好，但几乎没有罪恶感，对另一个人类的羞辱，恰恰相反。观众可能从中得到了很多。我只是想聊聊。我向你发誓，你知道，如果你……
How are you going to use the condoms in the car? I wasn't going to use them at all. When you got in your pocket, well, yeah, I do have to do balloon tricks with them. When envy and shard and friday play out among individual people, the outcomes tend to be limited. Feelings are hurt, a friendship ends, a colleague turns away. But when it comes to group behavior and group identity, these emotions can be far more destructive. If Richard's theory of envy and Schadenfreude in Hitler's Germany are true, these feelings may have contributed to the murder of millions.
你怎么在车里用避孕套？我根本没打算用它们。当你把它放进口袋里时，好吧，是的，我必须用它们做气球把戏。当嫉妒和幸灾乐祸在个人之间上演时，结果往往是有限的。感情受到伤害，友谊结束，同事转身离开。但当涉及到群体行为和群体认同时，这些情绪可能会更具破坏性。如果理查德关于希特勒德国的嫉妒和幸灾乐祸的理论是真实的，这些感觉可能促成了数百万人的谋杀。
You see similar things on a smaller scale in the United States. Richard Smith says Chardonnay Freud has become a powerful force in our politics, and it operates through the lens of partisanship. The increasing bottom line is whether one's party is gaining it some way. In one study, Richard and some colleagues asked college students for their emotional reactions to a variety of news articles. The articles described misfortunes happening to others, like stories of home foreclosures or economic woes. It turned out that the students with the strongest political party identification were also most likely to see the news through the prism of Shadon Freider. Some partisans fell joy when American service members
你在美国较小规模上也看到了类似的事情。理查德·史密斯说，幸灾乐祸已经成为我们政治中的一股强大力量，它通过党派偏见的镜头运作。底线越来越是某一方是否在某种程度上获益。在一项研究中，理查德和一些同事询问大学生对各种新闻文章的情感反应。这些文章描述了发生在他人的不幸，如房屋法郎或经济困境的故事。事实证明，具有最强政治党派认同的学生也最有可能通过幸灾乐祸的棱镜来看待新闻。一些党派成员在美军士兵时感到快乐
came home dead from the war in Iraq, because it made the other party look bad. We also looked at reactions to troop deaths when it came to Democrats just before they run up to the midterm elections. So it just, the fact remained that if you were winning George Bush to the Republican Party to do poorly, more troop deaths in Iraq would be a good thing in the sense of swinging the election.
从伊拉克战争中死里逃生回家，因为它让另一方看起来很糟糕。在期中选举前夕，当谈到民主党人时，我们还研究了对部队伤亡的反应。所以，事实依然是，如果你希望乔治·布什对共和党人的表现不佳，伊拉克的更多部队伤亡是一件好事，从左右选举的意义上说。
So, Democrats, more willing to sort of slightly feel or acknowledge that the bad news coming out of Iraq made them feel good to the extent they could see the political consequences. In the same vein a few decades ago, some Republicans felt pleasure knowing that President Jimmy Carter's Iran hostage rescued debacle would help their candidate in the presidential election, Ronald Reagan. This is terrible stuff. Minichikara believes that malicious envy and shard and fraud may in fact serve as a gateway to unspeakable acts. You know, a couple years ago when skirmishes in Israel started to heat up again, I think it was the summer of 2014, people started sending me a link to a story about people in the Gaza Strip or people in Israel who were sitting on their couches watching bombs get lobbed at the other side and cheering. And you know
因此，民主党人更愿意稍微感觉或承认，来自伊拉克的坏消息让他们在看到政治后果的程度上感觉良好。同理，几十年前，一些共和党人感到高兴，因为他们知道总统吉米·卡特的伊朗人质救援惨败将有助于他们的总统候选人罗纳德·里根。这是可怕的东西。Mina Chikara认为，恶意的嫉妒和幸灾乐祸实际上可能是通往难以言喻行为的门户。你知道，几年前，当以色列的冲突再次升温时，我想那是2014年的夏天，人们开始给我发一个关于加沙地带或以色列的人们坐在沙发上看着炸弹被投向另一方并欢呼的故事的链接。你知道
oftentimes I hear things like, oh the shot I'm for it, this is just relegated to the domain of sports or celebrity gossip, you know, context in which it really doesn't matter. But actually it turns out it's present in situation in the most dire of human conflicts in situations. If I feel good every time I watch a bad thing happen, maybe next time I'll make a bad thing happen. The research in this field is just beginning. It's still unclear how much the pleasure of Shardin Freider can lead to actions that cause harm. If an angry young man feels pleasure watching white supremacists assault someone, will
我经常听到这样的话，哦，幸灾乐祸，这只是被降级到体育或名人八卦的领域，你知道，这真的无关紧要的背景。但实际上它出现在最可怕的人类冲突和情况中。如果我每次看到坏事发生都觉得好，也许下次我会让坏事发生。这一领域的 RESEARCH 才刚刚开始。目前还不清楚幸灾乐祸的快乐能在多大程度上导致造成伤害的行为。如果一个愤怒的年轻人在看到白人至上主义者袭击某人时感到快乐，他会
he become a white supremacist himself? How much can our pain prompt us to find pleasure? And how much can this pleasure prompt us to cause pain? If we can be led by Shardon Freuda down a path of destruction, where does it end? We began this episode with the story of Jessica. She was left behind on an island with Dengue fever while her friend was airlifted to a modern hospital on the mainland. Jessica's envy was so intense, it caused her physical pain. It might have led to the end of a long friendship. But that didn't happen, and the reason it didn't is that Jessica brought her envy into the light of day.
他自己会成为一个白人至上主义者吗？我们的痛苦能在多大程度上促使我们寻找快乐？这种快乐又能在多大程度上促使我们制造痛苦？如果我们能被幸灾乐祸引领走向毁灭之路，它将在哪里结束？我们以杰西卡的故事开始了这一集。她被留在了一个患有登革热的岛上，而她的朋友则被空运到大陆的一个现代医院。杰西卡的嫉妒是如此强烈，以至于给她带来了身体上的痛苦。它可能导致了一段长期友谊的结束。但那并没有发生，原因是没有发生是因为杰西卡将她的嫉妒带入了白昼。
She exposed fully what she had been feeling. And that simple act, admitting to what we are taught to keep inside, allowed her ultimately to triumph over this emotion. Perhaps there's a lesson in Jessica's story, the first step to We have it. This episode was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Path Shah and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Liu. Our unsung hero this week is Adam Zisman. Adam is a lawyer at NPR and he's involved in many complex issues that come up when you run a journalism organization. I've gotten to know Adam as he and I have worked out the framework and business model for Hidden Brain.
她充分暴露了她一直以来的感受。这个简单的举动，承认我们被教导要藏在内心的东西，最终让她战胜了这种情绪。也许杰西卡的故事中有一个教训，第一步我们拥有它。本集由Jenny Schmidt和Path Shah制作，Tara Boyle编辑。我们的团队包括Raina Cohen、Laura Quarelle和Thomas Liu。我们这周的无名英雄是Adam Zisman。Adam是NPR的一名律师，他参与了当你运营一个新闻机构时出现的许多复杂问题。我和Adam有了交集，因为他和我都为《隐藏的大脑》制定了框架和商业模式。
We've had many long conversations over the years and I've always come away impressed by his tenacity and flexibility. Thank you Adam. If you enjoyed this episode, please tell a friend about it. We're always looking for new listeners to discover hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些年来我们进行了多次长谈，他的坚韧和灵活性总是给我留下深刻的印象。谢谢你，Adam。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉你的朋友。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现《隐藏的大脑》。我是Shankar Vedantam，这是NPR。你这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。